[Music]
hi
i'm sydney i run the diagnostics
development hub or dxd hub txt hub
is a national platform of singapore for
the purpose of
diagnostics productization it is funded
by the national research foundation
of singapore and hosted by a-star
a-star is agency for science technology
and research
of singapore so the title of my talk
today is anatomy of
diagnostics test so i will start by
going through
the process of product development of a
diagnostics test
so if you look at this uh
value chain of what it takes from the
lab to the market
we always start from the discovery of
course and it goes through the
translation
and then this process that we call
productization
most of us actually have heard about
this process being referred to as
product development
and the we like to call it
productization just to differentiate
that a little bit from
translation and then of course market
adoption
towards the end what dxd hub
has built and has been focusing on is
really this segment we call
productization and
market adoption and that is actually
linking
the output of r d to the
market adoption which is uh most of the
time
the end users would be the the
operator in the clinical diagnostics
labs
or the clinicians directly
and when we talk about r d output on the
on the one end
of the the value chain where the
translation is
we are really referring to the r d
output
and whether the r d output is coming
from a company
or it is coming from a public sector and
these are the outputs that dxc hub
will work with to take them downstream
and do the development and connect that
to the end users
what goes on in between is this a
v-shape that you see
at the bottom of productization and
market adoption
we always start from the user
requirement it's always
what does the product look like when we
actually take it out to the market
how how is the product going to be used
so we're not talking about a snapshot of
a test
it's really and therefore we call it the
anatomy of a diagnostics test
because it involves the whole workflow
not just a snapshot of a component
so we focus on these two elements in the
red line box
the end to end productization and the
agile process
so ntn productization basically means
that we start with the
end in mind we actually go out and
look at the usability and talk to the
users and see what the product should
look like
and then we go back to the beginning of
the productization
so you can see in those boxes at the
beginning of the productization it
actually says
functional prototype so functional
prototype is not just the
the prototype itself it's how it
actually works as a functional
unit and the system's integration
so it's very important to know how for
example in the diagnostics essay
how the essay works in whichever system
and you need to be able to integrate
that on a certain platform on a certain
system that's why we call it system
integration
and that's why we call it functional
prototype so we start with that
and then we actually do the verification
of that whole function
sitting in the system and before
so all that would be done before we go
down to clinical
validation so we always like to advise
our partners that we need to be able to
understand
as much analytical function
and performance of the product as
possible
before we go down to clinical validation
so what do we mean by the anatomy of
diagnostics test
if you look at this when we talk about
diagnostics test
it's never about the assay
essay is really one of the components of
a diagnostics test the diagnostics test
actually
starts from when the specimen is
collected
because you always need to consider what
are you
testing are you testing blood saliva
or a nasopharyngeal
specimen so those are all very important
part of the consideration
when you think about a diagnostics test
so we always start with
what is the sample type what specimen
are we using
and then we think about um the the test
the assay itself
uh are we looking at assay that will be
detecting
nucleic acid or we are looking at assay
that will be detecting
proteins after we consider what what
type of assay that we're looking at
depending on what analytes we're going
to be detecting
we then need to think about what system
the sa is going to be
running on is it going to be running on
if it is a
pcr essay there are so many different
types of pcr platforms on the market
there's no reason to reinvent the wheel
and you know build a pcr
system uh which type of the commercial
pcr system
you want to run your essay on and it can
be all of them
but every time you use one specific
system is
is a dif it's a whole new process of um
analytically verifying the performance
of your essay on that specific system
so that's why we always talk about
everything uh as a whole
rather than just the test itself just
the essay itself we need to think about
uh if it is a lab based test what is the
system
the lab is using is are we are we
looking at a high throughput
type test every time uh the lab is going
to be running
96 samples in a row or the lab is
a low to mid throughput type labs where
each time they only need to run 10 and
they can go
it's important to consider that because
it's a huge impact to your turnaround
time
because if the lab is a low throughput
lab and you build your product to
be running 96 samples in a in a row
it actually means that the lab has to
wait until they accumulate enough
samples before they can start to run
so so those are all consideration and of
course if you build your test to be
very very near patient side where you
actually don't need a lab
then it could be just a single test it's
a single user test
so so that is the throughput that the
system is part of the system that we are
we need to consider when we build um we
talk about diagnostics tests
and finally is the analysis the data
analysis
and what type of uh we call it the
testing regime
that you're talking about so how do you
analyze the data
um a lot of the tests today actually
come with also a very
specific software that would help the
user better analyze
the data and the regime of testing
whether you are doing a single test or
you're doing
you know nowadays in the covid pandemic
where there's a lot of
literature talking about pool testing um
just so that we are able to
increase our throughput every test that
we do
so for every test that we run we're
actually running five patient samples
in one test so that's what we meant by
pool testing so you we also need to
consider
that sort of regime because
if your test has been verified to
have a certain performance only by doing
one patient sample at a time
now if you want to run it in the pool
testing
format you are actually looking at
your tests being able to test five
different patient samples
in one test and that that could have
some implications to the performance of
your test because
there may be an increased concentration
of a
certain inhibition inhibitory factors
to your essay so those are all different
things to consider so
every single element that you change
in this whole um you know anatomy of the
diagnostics test
you would have to add that as part of
the consideration
in your productization process and you
need to actually
analytically verify that performance
before you can state that your test is
able to
do that so now that we understand what
it means when we talk about
diagnostics tests we can now look at
what it means by productization the
first box in productization
is essay optimization so although it
says
essay optimization when we look at the
optimization we have to think about
optimizing the whole system not just
optimizing the
essay itself um so if you for example if
you have a pcr
running on um you know a certain
instrument a for example then
the optimization that first box actually
is to optimize your essay
specifically on that instrument and
we need to very very early on
if you look under optimization it's not
just to optimize for the technical
performance
but it's also to optimize how well
um one can manufacture
this this product so in other words when
if you have you know if your reagents
come
in 20 different tubes
it does the same thing as if you are
able to simplify the 20 tubes into
10 tubes and it gives you the same
performance
from a manufacturability perspective
of course 10 tubes would be better
because it's much easier to manufacture
and it may actually bring the cost down
because in terms of logistics of
manufacturing
you know it is a little bit less
manpower and resource
constraint so those are the different
things when we talk about optimization
it's not just the technical performance
i think technical performance is
is is a is the fundamental
element that you need in order to make
sure that everything that you change
you always come back to your technical
performance to test that everything that
you change
downstream you come back to double check
that it has not changed your technical
performance
so manufacturability is something that
you do from
the beginning of the productization as
part of optimization
and of course as you move along the
productization workflow
it takes you to the
the really the deep end of
what it means by manufacturing workflow
so we look at the whole entire bill of
materials
we look at the whole entire
manufacturing
work instructions and these are the
things that
we do within dxd hub for the purpose of
helping our commercial partners
accelerate their process
because when we work with our commercial
partners
it is not just for us to license the
product
it's also for us to help them
manufacture
the pilot production is very important
as part of this process because at the
end of the day
you do need to make sure that the
manufacturing the production
will give you consistent performance
so you actually need to run through many
batches
of production and we do that within dxt
hub to run through a few batches of
pilot production
and we make sure that every single batch
has the same performance
because one of the one of the
requirements for regulatory is actually
are you able to manufacture
consistent batches every time that would
give you
the same performance all the time
normally what we do
is after the essay optimization
we would have we would have a small
a small almost preliminary
run of analytical verification to help
us
build the protocol for
product development and that helps us
build the
pilot production the manufacturing
workflow and
only after we are able to consistently
produce different batches that would
give you the same performance
after the pilot production stage then we
are ready to do the
full-blown analytical verification and
clinical validation
so that's when we actually produce at
least
three different batches and we run the
analytical and clinical performance on
those three batches that would form
the actual data that would need to go
into your regular 30a so this is really
the the you know the deep dive
into the real integrity of
what it takes to do productization so i
think
it's important to um elaborate and
deliberate this a little bit because uh
one thing that we
we deal with a lot when we do with
our partners that are taking their
um their ip their prototype to us and to
want to work with us
on a product um the i suppose one of the
the biggest misconception when we talk
about productization and product
development
is people always forget about this part
about production
um they could have done everything else
they could have
optimized the essay very very well they
could have done
you know all the analytical protocols
they could have even
taken the essay down to testing on
clinical samples
everything but they miss out on the
production
um and they you know they come to us and
say well we've done everything else but
how do we actually manufacture that in a
mass
production setting so
um that would almost take us back to
stage one
to start all over again to redo the
protocols
so that we are able to build the
manufacturing workflow into that
and so so we do actually
want to emphasize this point a little
bit so that for
you know those of us in the audience
that are looking at doing product
development for the first time
uh keep that in mind um
of course the the downstream of
productization
and uh market deployment is really
to a lot to do with the tech transfer
that take transferring that to our
commercial partners
and a lot to do with working directly
with the end users
so going to the labs going to the
hospitals talking to the clinicians
talking to the the lab managers the lab
operators
just getting some sense of how
the product is actually being used
sometimes they'll come to us and say
that our product has already been
verified
and validated on machine a but
they don't have machine a they have
machine b that does the same
function but it's not the machine that
we had validated
um it's very difficult to tell the lab
to say why don't you go buy one
so what we do is actually remember the
agile process so we actually do need to
continuously iterate
we come back and we would then need to
verify and validate the same
essay but on on a different platform so
on this
slide you see that these are
it's it's a pretty comprehensive list of
what it takes
to build a regulatory dossier i just
want to actually maybe just focus
on the three yellow boxes at the bottom
things like the
for example the storage media
compatibility
this is actually not very obvious but
very important
we very often hear feedback
about some essays that are
that are not working that well in fact
when you look at their
analytical performance on a piece of
paper on the regulatory
instruction for use they all look really
good
it's it's actually not possible
to compare essays on paper so you can't
really take
a different regulatory dossier of
different tests and compare them on
paper and to say that this one is
therefore better than the other one
because
this one has a lower limit of detection
and that one has a higher sensitivity
and so on because
um when you do when you work on a
product in an analytical setting they
are really based on
performance um with respect to a certain
standard
and unless and until you know
whether they are using the same standard
you can't really compare their
performance
side by side so normally the way to
compare
is actually in the clinical setting when
you're using the same set the same
cohort
the same clinical samples and then you
use them on different tests
and you get some sense of whether one
test is better than the other
and even in that setting it is very
important that
the users in the lab actually use the
the right
collection media for example the other
one is
whether you have actually tested the
analytical performance of your
test of your assay in that system
with respect to what kind of specimen
whether it is
in a blood or saliva and even saliva
there are many different types of saliva
saliva can be drooling saliva saliva
also can be deep throat saliva
you need to understand whether your
essay
has actually been proven to have the
same performance
in an analytical setting for the
different types of specimen
and then of course the platform so
different pcr platform has different
settings so
it is important for you to be able to
have tested them
in the lab and know exactly which
setting to use so that you're able to
better
advise your users and again if you think
about it from
if you think about product development
from the market perspective
you always have to remember that you
can't really dictate what
your end users will use in terms of
let's say a pcr machine
so you need to make sure that you give
your end users
as wide a choice as possible
in terms of whatever that they already
have your
essay is able to work on their system
this
slide actually shows the difference
between
resolute 2.0 and a conventional pcr test
so resolute 2.0 is a direct pcr test
what that means is it
it is a pcr where you don't need to do
an additional step of sample prep so
there's
absolutely no ironing extraction you
take the specimen directly
from collection point and then you put
it in the pcr
master mix and then pcr
so that can so that is what resolute
is on the top of the slide um
so you go from a sample collection
whether it is
uh specifically for for resolute 2.0
it is applicable to whether it is nasal
soap whether it is a throat swab or
nasopharyngeal swab
so resolute 2.0 is a copic 19 rtpcr test
it's a direct tpcr test for kobit 19.
so if you start from the first box of
the workflow on the top
we are looking at a sample specimen that
are either nasal
nasopharyngeal or throat and
then of course a certain transport media
and we have tested resolute 2.0
in a number of a
very very specific brand and type of
collection media and it's all stated so
that the users
are aware which are the ones that have
been validated
so if they're not using any of the ones
that have been validated and listed
then the essay may or may not perform
as well as what we had stated and where
the dotted line is basically
is where the lab process starts
so at the lab basically what you do is
you just add five microliter of
the sample directly into a master mix
and
you start the pcr reaction and the whole
process
should not take more than one and a half
hours the pcr
itself actually takes 60 minutes so we
are saying that
you know the taking the five microliter
of the
the patient specimen into the pcr well
depending on how many you do
if you do the whole 96 well um it could
take about 15 minutes
so all the way from the sample arriving
to the lab
and operators starting to work on the
sample to the finish
of the pcr to the result the report
coming out
is maybe about one and a half um
probably not more than one and a half
hours
so that's the whole workflow of resolute
2.0
compare that with the bottom of the
slide a conventional
conventional rt-pcr basically the
workflow
before lab is the same you um
take the swap and then you use a certain
collection media
the difference actually is what happens
in the lab
when the when the sample arrives in the
lab for a conventional rt pcr
you actually need to run rna extraction
the rna extraction here we put down one
and a half hours
so the one and a half hours actually
refers to
labs that actually have a
an rna extraction system that would be
able to run
96 sample um uh
you know at the same time so this is
actually in the context of running 96 uh
well um pcr so you're trying to do a 96
well pcr
then if you are a lab that
is equipped with um
rna extraction that is able to do 96 in
a row
then yes it would take about one and a
half hours but if not
if you're using you know worse if you're
using a manual system
you would be doing that one at a time it
could take multiple
hours even some of the other
systems that are able to do higher
throughput um but not
96 what that means is in order for you
to run a 96 well
pcr run you would have to wait for the
rna extraction
to finish so if your rna extraction
cycle can only do 14 in a row you have
to wait about
i don't know seven hours before you can
batch
enough to run one plate
so what that means is in that in that
system
it would take you about nine hours to do
one plate of 96
versus one and a half hours to do the
same
plate of 96 just the lag process itself
there's a wide range for conventional
rtpcr of three to six
hours depending on the rna extraction
system you use
in the lab even if you have a 96
sample rna extraction system it will
take you
double the time of direct pcr like
resolute 2.0
at the end of the day we are talking
about the turnaround time
and turnaround time is not just
having an essay that can run a test
very quickly but it is also about having
an
essay that may not need to
be very very quick but you can do 96
in a row so all that actually
would be part of the consideration when
we're talking about how do we increase
the throughput
resolute 2.0 is actually a process of
iterative
improvement we started resolute 2.0
from resolute 1.0 so that's what
actually this slide is showing the
the progress of how we continue to
improve
as a result of um feedback from users
and then we come back from the end to
end so we we went to the end users
we came back and we iterate and we
improve and then we went back
uh with an improved product as a result
of that so if you look at the
progression
of what we have done using this what we
call accelerated productization process
um it's taken us really only from april
to july to roll out three different
uh format of the same test
so we started with the resolute 1.0
where it basically does very much
similar things but in a slightly
different format
so the essay is slightly different the
system
is slightly different and if you look at
resolute one it's got 14 tubes in terms
of the reagents
and of course we very very quickly came
back and with an improved version
you know through the iterative process
of resolute two
where it is now only four tubes also
made some
changes in the way that the essay was
done
added differences in the how the system
is done
and very very recently in july what we
have added was
automation um automation to basically
remember you remember the the chart
where we talked about
when the when the sample arrives in the
lab
somebody has to actually allocate the
sample into the pcr mix
so that part is still quite manual
that part somebody actually needs to
uncap the utm tube
allocate into the 96 well play and then
kept the utn tube
we actually now have an automation
solution
sample prep for resolute two literally
is allocating
so the automation allows us to do that
so we
now are able to cut down even on
the human errors so we don't need to
have someone that is
in full ppe standing in front of the
biosafety cabinet doing
aloe potting for many hours in a row so
this actually shows
um a very nice picture
of the process as a result of the
process that we have developed in dxd
hub
to be able to very quickly um
go through not just to make the first
product but also
to iterate and to make to continue to
make improvement to push our pipeline
product
in response to the feedback from the
customers
after introducing resolute 2.0 i have to
introduce the teams that are responsible
for developing resolute 2.0
it was developed together by three teams
mainly the teams at dso defense science
organization dxe hub and our colleague
at artc
a star so the aitc a star team
was responsible for developing the
automation
to run the the sample prep for resolute
2.0
and the dxo team was led by dr tanbun
hon
the exe head team was led by dr juan
rayford and the iartc a star team
was led by dr david lowe so i
want to take this opportunity to um
to maybe highlight the the
a very very fundamental element which i
didn't talk about throughout the whole
presentation
was the fact that for any of this to be
possible i always like to tell people
that
the success of a diagnostics test
really is dependent on how well you work
with your partners
because of the iterative process that's
required for you to keep
improving your products so that you are
able to keep
having a successful
market deployment and market adoption of
your test i hope that short
presentation has given you
some understanding or better
understanding of what it takes to build
a diagnostics test
thank you